Artists and creators throughout history
have spoken of inspiration
practically from the cradle,
a tendency toward writing
or sculpture or music
from before they could speak.
Sharmeen Obaid Chinoy is
not one of those artists.
I was 21. I never studied film.
I've studied economics and government.
So I literally typed into this
search bar visual journalism.
And the word documentary films popped up,
and I was like, that's it.
I'm gonna be a documentary filmmaker.
Her films have won Academy Awards,
Emmys and numerous other honors.
She's become one of the
most influential advocates
for human rights around the world,
focusing specifically
on the plight of women,
in her home country of
Pakistan, and beyond.
I spoke with Sharmeen
about her insatiable desire
to speak truth to power,
and the power that comes
from listening closely
to those whose stories need to be told.
Women are realizing that they
want a say in their lives,
that they want to see in how
the government treats them,
that they want to see in having more space
in the public sphere.
And men are afraid.
Tell me about growing up,
your growing up years.
Because from everything that
I've read and heard about you,
it's so formative.
Your family is so formative.
From a very young age,
something was instilled in you.
I grew up in Karachi, Pakistan.
And, you know, I'm the
eldest of six children,
five of them girls.
I grew up in a family
that wanted the daughters
to have an education.
We were free to speak our minds.
And that was very encouraging.
From a very young age, I
realized that I had grown up
on the side of the tracks
where I was very lucky.
And I remember one particular instance
when I was about 10 years
old and I was driving,
I was going to school
and my car had stopped at a traffic light.
And I remember looking out of the window
and I saw a young girl,
she was about 10 years old
and she was barefoot and
she had her hand pressed out
and the nose was glued
to the window screen
and she was begging.
And I remember thinking,
why is she not in school?
And I always had these
questions, you know,
like, why is this not happening?
Why is that not happening?
Pakistan is a society
which frowns upon questions
that are probing.
You know, you're supposed
to accept the status quo.
This is just the way it is.
Don't talk about this. It'll bring shame.
And so I was that annoying kid in class
who would put up their hand all the time
and ask difficult questions.
And at home I did that as well.
And my mother was raising
five children was like,
you need to ask someone
else these questions.
And she encouraged me to write.
And I became a writer when
I was about 14 years old.
And I think I've never looked back.
Sharmeen's innate drive to ask questions
and seek the answers led
her to the United States
were she pursued her higher
education at Smith College,
that was despite her
family's initial reluctance.
Although she studied economics
and political science,
her experiences at Smith
ultimately led her down a different path.
You know, when I was on
campus, I had a lot of sit ins.
I was a very, I was involved
in student government.
I was junior class president.
I was very politically active.
And it gave me an opportunity
to meet people from around the world,
women who came from Africa and
Asia and the United States,
who, if you think, would have
had different experiences.
But let me tell you,
women around the world
share a lot in common.
It doesn't matter where they come from.
There is an inherent bias against women
that exists in almost
every society in the world,
whether it's in the north or the east
or the south of the west.
And I think that was a
transformative period for me
as a individual, because
right out of Smith,
I decided to take up
documentary filmmaking
and switch my career.
All right, so on that note,
you give me a great opening
to talk about what I
think is a pivotal moment.
I think you'll agree.
And I got a chance to catch up
with your colleague and friend Trish.
And she talked about meeting
you for the first time
and a pivotal moment that you have
with a very well known news organization
here in the United States.
When we met, it was in a coffee shop
and it was like realizing
that we shared the same goal
of finding voices that
weren't being heard,
giving them a voice, giving them a light,
and we were young at the time
and we didn't have connections.
And Sharmeen, like, marched
into the New York Times office
and said, you know, "I have a story
and I want to make a film."
And, you know, it was kind
of an outlandish thing to do
in your early 20s.
And she was able to do it.
And she went and she made
films on the front lines
of a lot of war zones in the Middle East
and came back and delivered these stories
from people who are
suffering from injustice
and whose voices weren't being heard.
And they made it to New York Times
and reached an international audience.
So that's a big moment, obviously.
Yes, it was.
You know, I was 21 years old
and I was writing for these newspapers,
and 9/11 had happened,
and I would watch the nightly news
and I would see all these people
catch up into South Asia and
into Afghanistan and Pakistan
and with very little understanding
of what the politics of the region were
and what was happening.
And I thought to myself,
I can tell stories
from that part of the world
to this part of the world.
And I've wrote up this
proposal for my first film.
I wanted to do a film
about the impact of the war in Afghanistan
on the youngest victims of the war,
which were the children of Afghanistan.
And I sent it off to about,
I mean, 80 organizations
in the United States.
Every production house I could find.
One day online, I found the e-mail address
of the president of the then
New York Times television.
And I emailed him and,
you know, 15 minutes later
he responded and I bought my first suit
and got on an Amtrak train
and went to New York.
And I pitched it to the editorial board
of The New York Times.
And they funded my first
film, my first feature film.
Sharmeen spent her first 15 films
in front of the camera,
amplifying powerful stories
through her own experience,
and with her own voice.
By 2011, she'd decided to put the focus
squarely on the lives and
struggles of her subjects.
That led to her breakthrough
film, "Saving Face,"
about women in Pakistan
who've been the victims of acid attacks.
The film earned her an Academy Award,
the first ever won by a Pakistani.
To all the women in Pakistan,
we're working for change.
Don't give up on your dreams.
This is for you.
I immersed myself in a
world where so many women
literally were disfigured
simply because they were
brave enough to say no,
no to violence.
When acid is thrown on your face,
your entire face carries
that mark forever.
When you wake up in the morning
and you see your face in the mirror,
you're reminded of that incident.
And telling this story was so important
because the legislation in Pakistan
was so weak around acid
violence at that time
that Daniel and I felt
that this was a story
we needed to tell.
We need to impact legislation
and in fact, the way
people saw acid violence
in the country.
I think the moment for me
in this film was when Zakia,
who is a woman who had had
acid thrown on her face
by her husband because
she wanted a divorce.
I remember walking in to
film her one morning and,
you know, half of her face was gone,
it had been disfigured
and she was peeling
apples for her daughter
and she was smiling
and they were telling jokes to each other
about cats and kittens.
And they were both laughing.
And in that mother
daughter moment, I realized
that these are some of the
bravest women that I have met,
because through this ordeal,
they have laugh and joke
and not forgotten that
they are, after all,
mothers and human beings.
And that's why that story really changed
the way I saw the strength of a woman.
And that clearly vault you to
a new level in your career.
You've become much better known globally
and also in your own country,
where obviously you're
well known at that point,
but this is a new level
and things start to accelerate for you.
Does it become harder or easier
as you gain more notoriety?
Pakistan does not take to well,
to having a woman who has a voice
and who's not afraid to do so.
And I think that when I
won my first Academy Award,
people suddenly realized
that I had a voice
and there were many who
wanted to silence it
because I was taking up issues
that they didn't want to taken up,
especially not on the global level.
And, you know, I would
wake up some mornings
and I would read social media
and I would learn some things about myself
I didn't even know were true.
And so, you know, there
were massive campaigns
that were started to discredit me.
But, you know, none of it can stick
because all I'm doing is
telling stories that are,
real stories that need to be told.
It's interesting that
we're talking about this
because I want to bring in
another interview about you
to have you watch with your friend Marvy.
Marvi Mazhar is a prominent architect
based in Karachi, Pakistan.
She's bonded with Sharmeen over
the important role of women
in Pakistani society.
I think Pakistan is so
open to ideas right now
and every different platform
from artist community,
from a bureaucratic level,
I feel they're giving that space to women
and generally to new ideas.
I feel Pakistan has a lot of potential
in giving that space to others.
It makes its mistakes.
It has its own teething issues.
But that's where people like Sharmeen
bring in a lot of perspective,
working with the government,
working with local diaspora
and then bringing and
knitting it together.
So I feel that we, all of
us are have the same vision
of making Pakistan on a platform
where it recognizes such
new ideas and new ventures.
So she seemed when I spoke
with her, very optimistic,
I think that comes
through in that comment.
Do you share that?
I do. I share the optimism.
And I'll tell you this,
that the Internet has changed Pakistan.
There is a free flow of ideas.
If you would ask me in my 20s
would I work with the government,
I would have said never.
But I do work with the
government in Pakistan
on projects a lot.
I currently am working with
the Ministry of Human Rights,
with the Ministry of Justice.
But I will also say this,
that it is a country
where you have to dance,
where you have to walk the fine line,
where you have to think about the project
that you're working on and
the personal repercussions
those would have on you.
And so I have learned to
navigate those worlds.
And when you live in Pakistan,
I think you're sort of born
with that navigation skills.
As Sharmeen's influence has expanded,
so has her portfolio.
Her 2016 short documentary,
"A Girl in the River,"
about honor killings of Pakistani women,
won her a second Oscar,
the first time anyone had
won twice in the category.
This is what happens when
determined women get together.
The film's international recognition
helped inspire legislation in Pakistan
that made honor killings illegal.
That closed a loophole
that had previously allowed
the practice to go unpunished.
My film deals with forgiveness
and how the law is manipulated,
and now they're going to change that.
She's also taken on subject matter
far beyond her home country's borders,
calling out what she saw as exploitation
in American college sports
in the documentary "Student Athlete."
She's also produced a
range of animated films
to broaden her audience.
In addition to thinking
about what to make,
she's also thinking about who's making it
and who's watching the finished product.
About four years ago, I
thought about my body of work.
I've created so many
films. Who's watched them?
You know, of course, I
have a global audience,
but locally, who's been
able to watch them?
The ones that are on the
Internet are still accessible
to the ones who have access to Internet.
And so I built a mobile cinema
that goes from village
to village, town to town,
showcasing not just my films,
but also films of other filmmakers.
And the idea was that we
would take these films
into the heartland, into
the towns and villages
where men and women and children
together could watch films
and have discussions afterwards.
And our films range from, for women,
how to inherit property
or how to get a divorce,
or if they're battered, you know,
which is a shelter, they can go to,
those informational films.
I feel like the choices I'm making
have a lot to do with ensuring
that the next generation
in my country has the
opportunities that I did
by exposing them to thoughts and ideas
and competing worldviews.
You've said something
that I wanted to get you to
talk a little bit more about,
which is men watching your films.
You know, globally, I feel
like men of all nationalities
are reckoning with our history as a sex,
our history as it relates to women.
How has your relationship
with the male population,
as it were, if you can
generalize, changed?
There are men in Pakistan who abhor me,
who cannot stand me,
who think that I should be silenced.
And that's because they're afraid
that women like myself
will take back power,
that we will no longer
be seeking permission,
that we will just grab it.
And at the same time, I have a lot of men
who come up to me at airports,
who come up to me at
public spaces and say,
"I want my daughter to be just like you.
I want her to be free.
I want her to be able to speak her mind."
So as Pakistan is a
society that is changing,
there will be people who
will love me and my work
and there will be people who
will dislike me and my work.
But I choose to hear the voices
that cheer me on to the finish line
and not the ones that
want me to be silenced.
You know, it strikes
me, as you're speaking,
that you're going back to
this this idea of balance
and in an interview you gave,
you talked about your desire and your need
to provoke anger sometimes
because anger leads to action.
And yet at the same time,
it feels like there's a tone
through so much of your work
that is about hope and encouragement.
And I do wonder how
you strike that balance
and how you go about doing that daily,
how you go about doing
that as you choose projects
and make films.
I think that anger is a
really important emotion,
because when you're angry,
then you're moved to discuss issues,
you're moved to push legislation through,
you're moved to ensure that that injustice
does not happen to anyone else.
But I think it's equally important
in the world that we live in today
when a 24 hour news cycle to have hope,
because if you don't have hope,
then you don't have a
desire to create change.
And so it's important
for me to show the wins
as much as it is important
for me to show the losses.
And I think it was a few years ago,
I decided that I no longer wanted
to talk about issues.
I wanted to talk about the champions
who were creating change,
who were working on those issues.
We understand that that issue is enormous.
We understand that it
probably outlive our lifetime,
but that someone is working on that.
And that gives us hope
that you're chipping away at something
day by day by day.